Have you ever thought about standing in the local
body elections?
It’s a great way to serve your community
and have a say on the future of this district.
We need new candidates for our Community Boards,
Council and Mayor and almost anyone can stand.
You don’t need any special qualifications, but like any job
there are certain qualities that can help make you a successful candidate.
These include, being well known or connected within your community
having good leadership or decision-making skills
and knowing the issues that are important locally.
So make a difference, nominations are open now.
Grab the form or find out more at waimakariri.govt.nz/vote2019